today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so this
past Friday just about every single
corporate media outlet uncritically
repeated obviously false unemployment
headlines which Donald Trump then used
to claim everything's going great in the
economy despite us still being in the
middle of the largest jobs downturn in a
very very long time with historically
high unemployment rates now the the
crazy thing about this is I told you
guys this was going to happen just two
weeks ago if you listen to this podcast
if you watch the YouTube clip I did a
story called you're about to get slammed
with garbage math and in that story I
specifically said when the economy
starts to recover you are going to get
hit with growth rates that will be based
on the absolute bottom of this disaster
so I gave the example air travel dropped
ninety-six percent and then you saw a
headline air travel up a hundred and
twenty percent well okay from the
decreased by ninety six percent number
it has doubled and I told you it would
happen with GDP I told you it would
happen with jobs numbers and it took
only two weeks and we're now seeing it
but it's actually even worse because
it's based on admittedly incorrect
numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics not only are they lying in
exactly the way that I predicted they
would be lying they aren't even
reporting what's actually in the BLS
jobs report and this is so important
that everybody understand so all day
Friday Trump and corporate media we're
reporting unemployment rate way down to
thirteen point three percent 2.5 million
jobs created the report says in it that
because of what's called a miss
classification error
the unemployment rate has been reported
three months in a row as being lower
than it actually is and was this was
reported by almost no corporate media
and we're going to show you the actual
numbers and one report from corporate
media that actually looked to get it
right but it was sort of like swept
under the rug so for context remember I
want a recovery I want coronavirus to
end I want the economy to recover I
never wanted anybody to die from
coronavirus I don't want a crappy
economy or death in order to hurt Donald
Trump and his re-election chances that's
an allegation that people like Donald
Trump jr. have made it's ridiculous okay
but we have to tell the truth and the
truth is not being told so let's get
right into the numbers back in April the
unemployment rate of 15 percent was
reported fourteen point seven percent
due to what's called the classification
error the real rate was 19% now for May
we just got the main numbers they are
saying the unemployment rate is 13.3%
while the actual rate is really sixteen
point three percent now to be totally
clear and honest this is still an
improvement from April to May and this
is still the worst unemployment we've
ever had dating back to 1948 when the
numbers started being tracked the way
that they are today so what the hell
happened here what happened is that
employees who should be considered
temporarily unemployed which does count
towards the unemployment rate were
instead classified as absent from work
for other reasons temporarily unemployed
counts towards the unemployment rate
that we know is the u3 that's the rate
that we're talking about here if you're
absent from work for other reasons it
does not count towards the unemployment
rate now usually absent for other
reasons would be something like you're
on a vacation or you're on extended jury
duty you're taking care of a child or
relative that's very different then your
business is closed and you are
unemployed even if the idea is you're
going to go back to work
that business reopens for some reason
and we really don't know what I'm not
implying that Trump tinkered with the
data they were very conspiratorial
claims about Trump forced the hand of
the Bureau of Labor Statistics that it's
a huge organization and absent evidence
of that I think it would be
irresponsible to suggest Trump demanded
fake numbers be published because they
did publish the real numbers they were
just in a footnote for some reason
people who should have been counted in
the unemployment rate in April and May
were counted as this other category
which artificially lowers the
unemployment rate the report says this
happened due to coronavirus related
business closures as unemployed on
temporary layoffs however it is apparent
that not all such workers were so
classified they claimed to be
investigating why the MIS classification
error continues to occur so this has now
happened three times in March the real
unemployment rate was five point four
they reported four point four in April
the real unemployment rate was nineteen
point seven they reported fourteen point
seven and in May the new numbers the
real unemployment rate is sixteen point
three they reported thirteen point three
so understand that from this same error
we now have three months of headlines
that are wrong almost exclusively
reported in the incorrect form by
corporate media I found one instance of
this being mentioned on Friday here's
Steve Rattner on MSNBC who actually said
hey you know what the there's different
numbers there that are at the actual
numbers take a look through this what I
think we are those of us or into these
weeds are finding is there is a note in
the BLS report today the asset of
methodology specifically relating to the
Cova problem and I won't get into all
the weeds on that but it but BLS is
noting that that issue has a three
percentage point impact on unemployment
and that and so that a number of
economists are thinking that the right
number be looking at us more like
sixteen percent or sixteen point three
percent I now again understand I am not
blaming Trump it is true that a bunch of
jobs were created in May
or at least rehabilitated jobs that's a
good thing but the unemployment rate is
still a record high of more than sixteen
point three percent the Trump
administration has been going crazy with
the economists were wrong well
unemployment was expected to hit twenty
percent at its peak and it hit 19 point
seven in April they just didn't report
that number except in a little footnote
they reported it as fourteen point seven
so the bragging about we know what's
actually going on the economists don't
know they predicted twenty they were way
off it's all been been predicted
accurately and I'm the first to tell you
that economists are notably bad at
making economic predictions but none of
this matters the Trump administration
has not only been touting these
incorrect numbers for four days now
they've already created campaign ads
around these incorrectly reported
numbers the jobs report says
unemployment is sixteen point three
percent we've never had anything this
high short of last month and they are
claiming victory and saying let's
reelect Trump based on these record
disaster unemployment numbers they're
living in a fantasy world and I fear
that it is going to work and we're going
to talk about this a little more later
on in the program okay we have some
friends on the right and some friends on
the left that are really missing the
mark on a story about Mitt Romney and :
Powell and potentially george w bush not
supporting Trump in the upcoming
election so here's what's going on in
the last 24 hours there have been
reports and interviews that former
Republican President George W Bush
current Republican senator Mitt Romney
lifelong Republican : Powell and some
others will not be supporting the
re-election of Donald Trump now it's
important to understand that that
doesn't mean they're necessarily voting
for Joe Biden we'll get to that in a
second the reactions from the right have
been completely predictable these are
loser
triggered Republicans who are either
jealous of Trump success or mad that
Trump doesn't listen to them or they
have personal grudges Don jr. tweeted
who cares that he actor said who gives a
you know what that I think it's : Powell
or Mitt Romney isn't going to be
supporting Trump sort of like these are
losers we don't care about them they're
not even really Republicans as far as
we're concerned predictable response
from the right I don't care but sadly
I'm seeing some really bad takes on this
from some people on the left and they're
mostly coming from the slice of the left
that is Berlant ly virulent ly
irrationally anti Joe Biden I've started
hearing from people on the left stuff
like David the reason Romney and :
Powell and maybe Bush aren't supporting
Trump is because Biden is so far right
that they are just more aligned with
Biden's politics they're Republicans and
Biden's basically a Republican that's
why they are doing this and everybody
should be criticized for it that is
absolute idiocy and it's time for people
to pull up their big boy pants and
understand what's actually going on here
come on with me let's let's take a
journey so first and foremost what
actually happened over the last 24 48
hours a couple different things number
one the New York Times reports that
former Republican President George W
Bush is not going to support the
re-election of Trump this doesn't mean
that he's going to vote for Joe Biden
and in his defense a spokesman for Bush
is saying the report is wrong George W
Bush is steering clear of politics which
quite frankly is a coy way of saying
he's not supporting Trump he may just
not be getting involved whatsoever but
that is where the George W Bush
situation stands as of right now not
really a denial that George W Bush
doesn't support Trump but simply just
saying he's not in getting involved in
politics right now a Bush's brother Jeb
Bush the former Republican governor of
Florida he says he's not sure who he's
going to vote for Mitt Romney current
Republican senator from Utah will not
endorse Trump and was by the way Mitt
Romney yesterday out
with protesters in Washington DC saying
a black lives matter neither will late
Senator John McCain's wife Cindy McCain
she will not be supporting Donald Trump
and here's Colin Powell yesterday on CNN
straight up telling Jake Tapper he's
voting for Joe Biden and so we're not a
country of just a president we have a
Congress we have a Supreme Court but
most of all we have the people of the
United States the ones who vote the ones
who vote him in and the ones who vote
him out
I couldn't vote for him in 96 and I
certainly cannot in any way support
President Trump this year so yeah I know
you didn't vote for him in 2016 I assume
based on the fact that you approved Joe
Biden when senator then-senator Obama
picked him to be his running mate
in 2008 I assume you're gonna be voting
for Joe Biden I'm very close to Joe
Biden and a social matter and on a
political matter I've worked with him
for 35 40 years and he is now the
candidate and I will be voting for him
so the reactions from some who have been
writing to me have been war criminal :
Powell is voting for Biden - war
criminals no surprise or Republicans are
voting for Biden because Biden's
basically a Republican this is an
indictment of Joe Biden
now you can dislike Joe Biden you can
choose not to vote for Joe Biden but the
bad takes about this are really painful
like it's cringe-worthy to watch
you've got people on the left in the
face of Republicans abandoning their own
party for what they see as the good of
the country and the people on the left
that are writing to me are criticizing
these Republicans and criticizing Joe
Biden come on guys you're looking
foolish for years we've been saying
wouldn't it be great if some Republicans
did what's right for the country instead
of just checking the party orthodoxy and
that's exactly what they are doing here
the better analysis is they are so
disgusted by what Donald Trump is doing
that
lifelong Republicans are saying I can't
stand with my party I can't actually
just go with the party orthodoxy I'm
going to have to support someone else
who I would normally never support never
mind publicly admitting it and you know
reminder Bush spokesman is denying this
anyway we don't know what's going on
with George Bush but it doesn't matter
certainly as far as : powell goes and
mitt romney
this should be be viewed as a good thing
a democratic candidate in the face of
absolute totalitarian a donald trump is
a reasonable enough diplomat that
lifelong republicans are okay saying
this time around i can't just check the
box that my party wants me to check I'm
not with the lunatics like Ted Cruz I'm
not with you know Tom cotton and these
whack jobs I am going to think for
myself and do what I see is good for the
country it should be applauded that
they're doing this now it's also a
really bad example of post facto
rationalization by some on the Left who
are now coming up with these criticisms
if Bernie convinced some Republicans to
vote for him it would be rightly cheered
if Biden does it it's because Biden is a
Republican come on guys give me a break
these guys are conservatives they're not
fascists so they aren't going to support
a president taking the country down a
very dark path and that's supposed to be
an indictment of Biden now of course at
the same time it's still true that Biden
is no progressive Biden is a totally
standard center-left Democrat he wants a
fifteen dollar minimum wage his health
care proposal would give about thirty
million people additionally health care
Trump's would take it away from about
twenty four to thirty two million
Biden supports the green New Deal as a
framework his tax program is better than
Trump's etc okay he's a center-left
Republican now meanwhile Democrats don't
need to celebrate these endorsements if
they don't want to right let's some
right-wingers see that Mitt Romney is
saying no to Trump see that : Powell is
saying no to Trump let them evaluate
what that means for how they're going to
vote and meanwhile Joe Biden
just keep running his campaign we're not
whitewashing the records of these
Republicans these Republicans can be
horrible people who govern terribly and
are just making one correct decision
here right that it that's all it has to
be and quite frankly the second that a
Democrat is elected to president these
guys likely won't be our allies anymore
we simply agree that Trump is such a
systemic danger that must be removed
that they can't vote for him just
because there's an R next to his name
and that should be applauded that should
be applauded meanwhile we'll go right
back to arguing about taxes and forints
policy and the entire thing as soon as
Donald Trump is removed then a
Democratic president takes over we are
fighting a proto-fascist here don't miss
the forest for the trees I'm ready for
your disagreements I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman I look forward to hearing from
you remember to sign up for free to get
the daily David Pakman show audio
podcast on iTunes stitcher Spotify
Pandora Google Play podcast whatever
your favorite podcasting software is get
the daily audio podcast if you prefer
that
to youtube clips as an example let me
know your thoughts about these
Republican abandonments of Trump on
Twitter where you can find me at beep
Hackman the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue ChiCom and use promo code David you
will get your first shipment completely
free just pay five dollars shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com all right today's new members
of the day are Demetrios me AAPIs and
john hall also a big thank you to Susan
blue Susan is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day Susan's
been a member
almost five years dating all the way
back to 2015 thank you all so much for
your support grab a membership as well
as all of the great perks that come with
it at join pakman.com it won't hurt a
bit
and it takes under a minute to sign up
and it really does support the work that
we're doing ok we have to talk about the
rapidly spreading a meme or demand or
talking point this idea of abolish the
police and this has basically three
forms sometimes it's literally abolished
the police sometimes it's defund the
police and sometimes it's simply called
ACAB all cops are bastards the some
version of this is essentially what
we're talking about here now I believe
that this catch-all is completely
miscalculated I believe it's inaccurate
and I believe it dramatically helps
Donald Trump get reelected if it were to
become a prominent theme of Democrats
and and I can't believe Joe Biden would
do it but if Joe Biden were to adopt
this in the time remaining between now
and the election I'll tell you why and
then we can talk about it we have a
problem with police brutality in the
United States we have a problem with
lack of proper training for police we
have a problem with militarized police
departments in this country we have a
problem with lack of police
accountability in the United States we
are seeing overwhelmingly peaceful
protests demanding that these issues be
dealt with and that's a beautiful thing
they were catalyzed by the horrific
killing of George Floyd in Minneapolis
and protests like this and rallies like
these have not been seen in the United
States for a long time and it is a great
thing but abolish the police defund the
police sometimes the messaging can seem
inspirational or catchy but it doesn't
actually make any sense and it's not
popular and it is a huge risk if the
left is going
adopt this as part of a platform heading
into November abolish or defund the
police is using a sledgehammer when what
you need is a velvet glove and I'll
explain why and I'll defend my position
on this and then if you disagree I want
to hear from you the problem is just not
as simple as police have too much money
and if we take the money away we solve
the problem the problem is not as simple
as police need to be eliminated and then
we would be much better off including
replacing police altogether with social
service agencies or community watch
groups or whatever the case may be the
problem is sometimes too much police
funding for the wrong things the problem
is sometimes lack of training the
problem is not enough funding in some
cases and that can actually be the cause
of the problems we're trying to solve so
let's just get really specific about it
let's start with one example many police
departments have become militarized like
armies this is something I talked about
last week and I mentioned last week and
this is super important police training
in the United States is too short and
doesn't deal with how police officers
should actually be trained to be better
stewards of their communities and to
de-escalate situations rather than
escalate situations in many countries
police training is much longer than in
the United States that costs more money
but that extra training should not be
focused on riot control with rubber
bullets it should instead be social work
type training if police were trained
more like social workers and less like
soldiers if police were equipped with
de-escalation tools rather than military
vehicles then we would eliminate many of
the disastrous outcomes that we have
because the first instinct of more
police would be to de-escalate rather
than to say is this a time to pull a gun
or to use a taser taser or to pull out a
nightstick or baton or shield or police
a military a military vehicle but the
reality is that could cost more money it
could cost
more money to better train police for
longer if you double the amount of time
police officer spend in training from 13
to 26 weeks it's likely that is going to
cost more money not less and so the
sledgehammer of abolish the police or
defund the police fails to actually
achieve what we want I mentioned
militarization when a police department
is militarized they see themselves more
like a military force than as members of
the community and they solve problems
with the tools that they have again
shields military type vehicles riot
control tactics pepper pepper spray
balls and the like in this case we need
to demilitarize the police now you might
do that by strategically cutting funding
for certain types of training and
equipment in order to achieve the
demilitarization of police beautiful
brilliant I'm all for it but again
defund the police or abolish the police
does not actually leave us better off
now in some police departments the
problem is they don't have enough
funding they can't hire enough officers
they can't do community activism and
involvement so when a police department
is underfunded they resort to the cheap
policing of what we call low-hanging
fruit if you are underfunded and police
aren't properly trained and you don't
have the resources you need to get
police involved in the community you
basically just sent up tons of cops to
poor areas you send the cops you have to
poor areas and as we know those areas
are disproportionately non-white and
they hang out there maybe they do stop
and frisk or similar type tactics and
then they just rack up arrest simply by
saying you know we we don't we send
people to the areas where we believe
there is the most crime and of course
because that's the only area they are in
they find crime there and nowhere else
and it gets up there arrests numbers and
it's the self-fulfilling prophecy that
we know so so well so that's an example
where the police department might
actually be better if they were better
funded not to get shoulder mounted RPGs
and riot gear but to actually have
proper levels of staffing to
be involved in the community to be
trained in de-escalation like social
workers let me give you one more example
of this a a lot of police are policing
places where they don't live and in fact
sometimes there's a big divide where you
have officers who live in rural areas
outside of a city policing an urban area
and this is not a good thing for a
number of different reasons when you
bring when you have community members
policing their communities you typically
are going to be much better off because
you don't have Outsiders coming in the
people in the community are going to be
better disposed to the police because
it's not these outsiders from some other
place who just come in and do whatever
and then they leave and they sleep
somewhere else at night and you are
going to have police officers that are
more actually taking a stake in the
long-term effects of their policing
rather than just doing the easy stuff
the low-hanging fruit as I mentioned but
in big cities you might need more
funding in order to do that the reason a
lot of police don't live where they are
working is it's too expensive so this is
not me saying give everybody raises you
know umbrella but the point is in order
to achieve something that would improve
a lot of police departments requires
some percentage of the force to live in
the area that they police it might not
be cheaper you may not be able to do
that simply by defunding so I am is
disgusted and enraged as you are by the
horrifying videos of sick police
brutality from the last ten days of
protests my question is is the funding
or abolishing police really going to
solve the problem now a couple other
things that I want to mention we should
have a central database of bad police
actors so that when there are complaints
and when there are dismissals it's
harder for an officer to hide that when
they go and apply somewhere else and
it's harder for the new two Police
Department to say we had no idea you
have a central database of bad police
actors the unions will likely oppose
this it would be a fight but it would
cost money to maintain such a database
civilian review review boards for police
use of force complaints and police
shootings some cities have done this
that can cost money mandatory police
cameras that can cost money now
hopefully you'd be able to reallocate
funding away from militarization and
towards cameras etc but again the
catch-all of abolish or defund does not
take into account any of these details
one last thing here as progressives we
should be for government and state
involvement where it makes sense we want
the government involved in health care
for example they're not enough involved
right now we want the government
involved in regulating industry they do
not regulate themselves effectively when
it comes to law enforcement we actually
want government doing it and not the
people because the people sounds nice
when you imagine neighborhood watches
and and how that will work but you have
two problems first the people in your
neighborhood quickly become some private
security firm with the best lobbyists
and can get the most weapons you know
Google cops you get free with ads but to
get better service get Amazon Prime
police and by the way it comes with
being able to watch some TV shows for
free as well we don't want that it will
become the police equivalent of private
prisons or private mercenary firms that
fight wars overseas for us it's not the
progressive option secondly there is no
denying that sometimes you actually need
the scope of state and government
missile defense as a private endeavor
where neighborhoods decide here's how
we're gonna defend ourselves from
missile attacks doesn't really work well
and in the case of policing you need
these state and federal law enforcement
resources to deal with things that are
big like human trafficking it's too big
and too complex for communities and
private industry to deal with human
trafficking and the global federal state
and local elements that need to be
combined so the solution that is
progressive is not defund or abolish the
police its elect the right people to fix
the police ensure that the police are
working for us in the way that we want
and you do that in part by electing the
right people to make those decisions
change the mayor change the governor
change the police chief now one more
thing should other areas have more
funding yes do we need more funding for
teachers in education of course do we
need more funding for public health and
public housing and homelessness and of
course we do that is a separate issue
from defund or abolish the police
absolute last thing on this defund the
police is being hugely boosted by BOTS
online because they know it's divisive
and I hate to tell you that it'll help
trump defunding the police as of two
days ago has 16% support in this country
it's very low there is more support than
ever for reforming the police we
previously discussed did it make sense
in 2018 for Democrats to run on abolish
ice even if you support it I don't
believe that that would have been
logical in 2018 I see no evidence that
abolish the police is a good platform
and I believe that it will help Donald
Trump to get reelected if Joe Biden were
to adopt it it would dramatically hurt
his chances of winning in November if
this is still a very prominent issue at
that point tell me where you agree or
disagree okay let's now dig further into
the idea of what government should and
shouldn't be involved in which is a
really major part of the conversation
about police departments we've already
talked about calls to abolish or defund
the police in light of the protests and
the killing of George Floyd there's a
bigger question implicit in that
discussion which is what should
governments be involved in and what
shouldn't governments be involved in and
this is a question that really tracks
political views because on one side you
have extreme small government
conservatives and libertarians they will
sometimes go as far as to say roads
should be privatized you can pay the
owner to use whichever road you want or
look for a different Road another
example would be the privatization of
law enforcement where if you want to be
able to call the police you pay some
kind of a membership fee to the law
enforcement company that you prefer
Google cops or Amazon police or whatever
these are extreme examples but there are
some small government libertarians that
believe this stuff on the extreme other
hand you have truly communist
governments where the government would
potentially own all
of the industry and be the sole employer
they manufacture the vehicles the
government employs the doctors owns the
hospital's owns every restaurant decides
what food rations people get and what
farmers need to do with the crops that
they grow these are two extremes we have
no examples of success in the modern
world for either of the two extremes
because like with most things the devil
is in the details this is gray area so
let's dig into it my starting point as a
Social Democrat is that there are many
things government should be doing
instead of private industry but we
should be able to articulate a
compelling reason for why the government
should be involved instead of private
industry so in other words government
should not be the only provider of a
good or service unless there is a
specific case about why they should be
one of the most important things that
governments should be doing in
industries where they are not
participating is setting the ground
rules which I call regulation I don't
need government providing for example
car insurance but I do want government
saying to private businesses if you want
to be in the market of offering car
insurance here are the rules you have to
abide by similarly I don't want the
government running airlines and making
the airplanes but I do want government
heavily involved in saying if you're
going to build airplanes here are the
ground rules if you are going to sell
tickets to fly people around here are
the ground rules you need to adhere to
now most examples are pretty easy to get
agreement on for example very few people
believe the government should be the
sole manufacturer of mobile phones and
we've got plenty of companies Samsung
Apple and others that are innovating in
that space and making mobile phones and
that's fine but we'll get back to mobile
phones because there are complexities
that come in when you introduce
externalities which justify the role of
government now on the other hand most
people do believe that government should
be responsible for police departments
and law enforcement missile defense
defending the country from a foreign
attackers a stopping terrorism etc and
as I mentioned in the other
segment you might think that it's a good
idea to leave something like human
trafficking to nonprofits and community
groups but this is stuff with such a
massive legal infrastructure and so big
and wide-ranging
I do want a properly functioning
government law enforcement apparatus to
be dealing with something like human
trafficking correctly so the small
government versus big government ideas
are very often theoretical they're about
principles but you've got to do way more
work to really figure out how our
economy should be organized health care
is something I want government more
involved in health care there are
examples from all over the world of
government being involved in health care
and the health care being better health
care is an exception as I mentioned we
need a compelling reason to say this
should be pulled out of for-profit
markets when we're talking about
people's health I don't believe at a
moral level that that should be
something a subject to the whims of
companies looking to make profits so as
a social democrat i would say health
care meets the requirement to be pulled
out of for-profit market-based and then
you've got gray area so like i don't
need the government running all the
hospitals or employing all the doctors
necessarily but maybe I just want them
being the insurance company negotiating
prices establishing ground rules okay
that that's something that that I would
want let me give you another gray area I
want the government doing lots of
infrastructure spending I want them
improving our airports and our roads and
our bridges I don't need the government
running the construction companies or
being the construction company and
buying the bulldozers and the skid
steers and doing it all themselves I'm
fine with government hiring private
industry to do the actual infrastructure
work the problem is when the process of
hiring private industry becomes a crony
capitalist snow job where the jobs are
given to the president's friends so I'm
a Social Democrat I do think that
markets when they actually are well
regulated and function fairly direct
resources where they are most useful
from a utility point of view and
sometimes we have to say this area of
society should not be subjected to the
market calculation of where the most
utility is derived health being one of
those examples I don't believe for a
second this BS that we hear about
industries have incentives to regulate
themselves government doesn't need to
regulate because if the business does
something bad the PR will be terrible
news reports about them will make them
lose money just doesn't work doesn't
work consider a company that makes cars
and they pollute and harm some town
that's downwind and people in that town
get way more lung cancer over the 20
years after the cars have been
manufactured that's an externality now
you could say well the bad PR of people
hearing about that is going to make
fewer people buy that company's cars and
so the company has an incentive not to
pollute in order to keep selling more
cars and avoid the bad PR just doesn't
happen these externalities are only
often loosely assignable to a specific
action by a company oftentimes even if
the company gets sued it is cheaper to
pollute and kill a bunch of people and
every once in a while you just pay some
civil lawsuit so the point here is the
externalities are not properly dealt
with by markets and that is the role of
government regulation so the takeaway is
I want most areas of life operating in
well regulated markets with the profits
properly taxed to ensure that everyone
has a decent standard of living
I want industry to operate in a market
with enough safeguards and
infrastructure and it is not to their
advantage to hurt people in order to
earn the profits that they are earning
that's why the regulation has to be
strict enough and in some cases I
actually want the government
participating in the market rather than
just regulating it health care being an
exception an example of that so this
stuff is complex the principles people
who talk about liberty and
non-aggression and they just want to
talk abstractly they
often don't want to do or aren't able to
do the difficult work of really digging
into the specifics and you have to do it
in order to really get anywhere on this
stuff we're gonna continue talking about
this on the david pakman show instagram
page at david pakman show make sure
you're following us there
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
so Donald from fist got is worst polling
during this campaign so far down to Joe
Biden by 14 points nationally and these
are just unconscionable numbers and a
report from Axios about what's going on
inside the Trump White House and inside
the Trump campaign shows panic fear
anger at what's going on so this latest
poll from CNN CNN is rated as a B+
pollster by 538 their polling is pretty
good
they have Trump's approval down to 38%
that rivals the lows of Trump's
presidency and then in terms of Biden
versus Trump for November this poll has
Biden at 55 Trump at 41 now what's
important about this poll other than
Biden's absolutely ridiculous 14-point
lead is that Biden is well above 50% if
you look back to June of 2016 in other
words this time in the 2016 election
Hillary Clinton was very rarely hitting
50% you can go back and you can find a
poll here or there where Hillary had 50
maybe 51 but in June of 2016 Hillary
Clinton was mostly polling in the low
40s and occasionally in the high 40s
with the occasional 50 or 51 Joe Biden
is now regularly polling at 50% and/or
more in recent polls and that is a very
different starting point then where
Hillary Clinton was back in June of 2016
now the differences Biden's running
against an incumbent
whereas Hillary Clinton running against
Trump was two challengers or two
potential candidate
and there is some degree to which one
might expect as we get closer to the
election people will break for the
incumbent and that would certainly
benefit Donald Trump so publicly Trump
is insisting that he's doing really well
he very often will tweet versions of
what he tweeted this morning this
morning saying quote ninety-six percent
approval rating in the Republican Party
thank you the source is never cited the
source is never clear but Trump posts
that all the time and publicly he's
pretending that he's doing really well
and that Joe Biden can't win unless you
know Democrats cheat in the fall or
something like that which is hilarious
by the way privately Donald Trump's
aides and advisors are coming to him and
telling him these polls don't look good
and you need to do something they know
how bad the polls are a source briefed
on internal polls is calling them quote
brutal and seeing a major drop-off in
independent support while Trump's
Republican support is remaining
relatively high his Democratic support
is extremely low independents have been
shifting away from Trump significantly
in the last few months the of when the
looting starts the shooting starts thing
that Trump said is troubling for some of
Donald Trump's top aides and clearly
they know that Trump's disgustingly
divisive reaction to the protests have
heard him and they are saying Trump
needs to instead give a message of hope
optimism and unification and from that
recommendation came this idea that's now
being floated about maybe Trump could
give a quote major speech on race now I
have to tell you as hilarious as a major
speech on race would be from Donald
Trump I don't even know that I would
cover it normally I would you know
stream major presidential speeches but I
don't know that I would cover that it
would be merely a propaganda piece Trump
probably would barely even understand
what he was reading off of his prompter
it would be calculated to try to get a
few more points in a poll and I don't
even know that I would cover that speech
now a few insights into a zoom call that
took place with Trump's top campaign
advisers Corey Lewandowski asked the
question what is our message which is a
relevant question it's
clear what Trump's message is right now
they seemed to settle on the idea of
something like a great American comeback
theme the idea of using those
misreported jobs numbers from last week
to build this optimistic comeback
strategy for the next five months that's
going to be tough because Donald Trump
on one hand is appealing to his hardcore
base with his wild and hateful and
divisive rhetoric talking about sending
in the military ominous weapons that
doesn't play well with a lot of people
but if Trump switches to a unification
message to try to get his polling up
it's not clear that that's going to play
well with his hardcore supporters what
would be nice would be for Trump to say
hey you know what guys we failed we
failed the country has lost confidence
in me if they ever had it we are all
going to be resigning we failed we are
failures and I'm sorry that's what
should happen it will never happen they
are going to have to be removed when you
get a tick and it attaches to your body
and you try to just pull it off you
can't the tick hangs on for dear life
they are going to have to be removed
like a deer tick you're gonna have to
pour alcohol on it take tweezers squeeze
it by the head and try to get it to
release its grip on your skin that's the
analogy of how they're going to have to
be removed these are some of trumps best
worst numbers ever but at the same time
38% of the country thinks he's doing a
good job that is horrifying and it means
he can win in November and I don't know
if the 38% are people who are cult-like
in their following of Trump or what he
does doesn't matter or they're not
paying attention or they don't care or
they're cognitively impaired I don't
know what it is but he still has 38
percent support he can still win and we
need to get out there and make sure that
we prevent the re-election in November
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar is now claiming that the pepper
spray used to clear the path from the
White House to st. John's Church is
quote not a chemical irritant this is
the latest version the latest defense of
the now 7 day old photo op that Donald
Trump
did which ended remember with Donald
Trump awkwardly holding a Bible in front
of st. John's Church last Monday we had
video for you
from last week of protesters clearly
being gassed and dispersed with horses
you can see the gas rising as protesters
flee so the first statement the White
House put out was no tear gas was used
seemed like an obvious lie and indeed
eventually a statement was put out I
believe by the Park Service saying we
were wrong when we said it was incorrect
to say that tear gas was not used that
was not true so then William Barr who's
a completely sinister character in this
entire Greek tragedy of the Trump
administration Trump's attorney general
a general defended the use of what they
used by saying listen they were warned
multiple times before we started
deploying the crowd control elements
like gas and we'll pick it up there
here's William Barr saying once police
met resistance from protesters yes it
was appropriate to use tear gas to clear
a path for Donald Trump take a look
resistance yes they announced three
times they didn't move by the way there
was no tear gas used the tear gas was
used Sunday when they had to clear 8th
Street to allow the fire department to
come in to save st. John's Church that's
when tear gas was used there were
chemical irritants the part no they were
not familiar against pepper spray is not
a chemical irritant it's not chemical
pepper spray you're saying pepper bulls
and you believe that was program so bars
says everything was justified teargas
was not used and pepper spray balls are
not a chemical irritant so let's go
through these claims one by one first
teargas wasn't used local reporters went
through the area after this fiasco and
they collected used canisters of CM
speed heat CS and CM scat shell OC these
are two types of teargas now is it
possible that that was teargas left over
from the previous day as William Barr is
claiming that the previous day Sunday
Monday they used tear gas guess it's
hypothetically possible doesn't seem
hugely likely so that part bars saying
tear gas wasn't used appears to be a lie
then we get into the semantics thing
tear gas versus pepper spray they are
both chemical irritants each uses a
different irritant pepper spray uses
capsicum which comes from the active
compound in hot peppers tear gas is a
halogen compound that is powder like at
room temperature so in the most
technical sense these are two different
things but the CDC classifies pepper
spray as a form of teargas so it becomes
merely a semantic argument now lastly
Barr says pepper spray is not a chemical
irritant well it is an irritant this
issue of chemical is that the chemical
is one that exists in food as well
it's a highly concentrated version of
the irritant in peppers so what bar may
be is leaning on is that it's a natural
element rather than a lab maid chemical
but when you're talking about hot
peppers and going through a process
where you extract the irritant from the
peppers concentrated into a pepper spray
the fact that it's quote naturally
occurring seems irrelevant and William
bar you know he seems to be suggesting
that this is no different than tossing
some jalapenos at protesters this is a
highly concentrated very powerful
irritant that once again the CDC
classifies as a form of teargas so it's
gas lighting and it's deception all
around and William bar a horribly
sinister figure in the Trump
administration once again the david
pakman show at david pakman
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
we are in the middle of a global hundred
year pandemic the highest unemployment
since 1948 which is the first year that
unemployment was tracked under the
modern system the largest nationwide
protests that we've seen in a very long
time these over police brutality and one
of the highest numbers of horrifying
police brutality incidents that this
country has seen in such a short period
of time in decades and Donald Trump set
a new record for himself sending out 200
tweets and retweets in a single day on
Friday the president cannot lead and
instead he's tweeting from behind his
bunker fact base which track this
tweeted we're wrapping the day at 200
tweets for Donald Trump most for the
account ever period at 468 tweets it's
the most in a week for Trump during his
presidency and 74 tweets between 8:00
and 9:00 a.m. the most in an hour ever
as you can see there if you're looking
at the chart along with me June 5th
surpassing January 22nd with 200 total
tweets and retweets the most of any data
in Donald Trump's presidency Donald
Trump is now tweeting by the way from
behind 2 miles of fencing and barricades
much of it installed over the last week
as bunker boy as many are calling him
further isolates himself from reality so
there are about five or six different
relevant layers here first of all I'm
not President of the United States I
just have this show I don't have time to
tweet nearly 200 times in a day on a day
where I tweet a lot where I feel like I
probably tweeted too much today I might
tweet 15 times maybe if I do a bunch of
retweets maybe 20 times and and I'm not
President of the United States that's
the first story secondly this day Friday
included 74 tweets in an hour between
8:00 and 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time that is
more than a tweet per hour
a tweet per minute for an entire hour
that is an unhealthy level of social
media use which raises further questions
on its own number three again we're in
the middle of a global hundred year
pandemic highest unemployment since 1948
a huge nationwide protests huge police
brutality issues and Donald Trump sets a
record for himself tweeting and
retweeting 200 times in a single day
that doesn't make sense we need a leader
who can lead and do things now some of
you will say well Trump can't lead so
we're better off with him just sitting
around tweeting but the tweets are
actually doing damage it's not like the
tweets are neutral he's still doing
damage by tweeting number four Trump
just got done attacking Twitter and he's
using it more than ever
why not get away from Twitter if Twitter
is treating him so terribly because he
simply can't and that gets us to the
clinical aspects of this I spoke to a
couple of mental health professionals
over the weekend and they all had a
similar version of the same thing to say
which is essentially that Donald Trump's
behavior as we now see it on Twitter is
compulsive and obsessive and it's a sort
of decompensation of sorts his behavior
is the type of behavior that you know if
your coworker at Best Buy is behaving
this way if your coworker at an
accounting firm is behaving this way
you'd probably go and talk to HR and say
something's not right here
it's manic behavior it's compulsive
behavior you might have some kind of an
intervention there might be a
psychiatric evaluation done at a certain
point that's the type of behavior that
we're seeing from Donald Trump now one
last thing you might have noticed that I
didn't go through and read individual
tweets of Donald Trump during this
segment and there's no shortage of
tweets that I could have read we are
past the significance of any one of
Donald Trump's tweets in general now if
Donald Trump tweets something that
specifically newsworthy or actionable if
it relates to some new policy that his
administration is going to be rolling
out if it's a direct attack on an ally
if there's some kind of particular
relevance I will tell you what the
content of Trump's tweet
is but what happened on Friday 200
tweets and retweets
it's just erratic behavior and I don't
want to glorify or lend credence to any
one message that Trump sent by actually
reading the tweets you know it was a
combination of lies and smears and
attacks and bragging self-congratulation
retweeting right-wing trash and
conspiracy theories that's what it was
that's the summary the individual tweets
really were irrelevant they didn't
communicate any particular policy they
were mostly smears of other people so I
am NOT going to give them more
credibility or attention than they need
other than to point out 200 tweets in a
day is bonkers and this is the President
of the United States that is where we
will leave it and certainly if Trump
does actually tweet something relevant
to policy I will tell you what it is
fear not we have a voicemail number that
number is a two one nine two David P I
got a voicemail early this morning I
actually don't know what this person is
talking about I just I think they're mad
at me it's not clear for what see if you
can help me figure it out these are so
frickin foolish the only station is Fox
News you have NBC ABC the freakin
newspaper and you want to say the only
station that was for you for against you
is Fox News you people are so freaking
pathetic I don't know how you live with
yourself I really don't know what this
person is talking about I'm trying to
think of what I said I don't know that
I've ever said Fox News is the only
anything it's not the only pro Trump
media outlet it's certainly not a
liberal media outlet it's not I mean I
just have no idea what this person is
talking about if somebody has a better
recollection from from last week's shows
and you maybe can tell me what it is
this person's talking about please let
me know because I have no clue what it
is okay we have a very important bonus
show today every day we do an additional
show
there's the show that is ending soon and
then there's the next bonus show which
is every single day for our paid
subscribers okay we are going to talk
about qualified immunity for police
accused of misconduct this is a really
important apparatus that were it removed
or limited would make it easier to go
after police when they behave badly the
Supreme Court is weighing qualified
immunity we're going to talk about it on
today's bonus show number two Fox News
put up this crazy graphic essentially
showing how well the stock market
sometimes does when there are tragic
incidents like black people being killed
by police or riots or different things
we are now going to tell you not only
what the graph said but Fox News has
apologized and hey you know what Trump
never apologizes at least Fox News is
apologizing that's something we can say
and then lastly the editor of The New
York Times has resigned after backlash
over an editorial written and published
written by Republican Senator John
cotton Tom cotton and published by the
New York Times blowback has now led to
the editor James Bennett resigning is
this the right thing we are going to
talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
and remember to get the daily free
podcast on itunes google play Spotify
Pandora stitcher or whatever podcasting
program or app you prefer the daily
audio podcast a very popular way of
consuming the show for many of our
viewers I encourage you to check it out
we'll see you on the bonus track
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video